My collageal carcinoma is an andocarsinoma and is metastatic and recently metastasized to another area of my liver.
Is there, are there other supplements like modified citrospectin or more Artemisidin that would help with metastasis?
Are there other right frequencies that I should be doing?
This question first, if you have metastasis, so you have liver cancer that metastasizes to the liver.
Well, that's an easy thing, it's still liver cancer.
But if you have liver cancer that metastasizes to the colon, it's still liver cancer.
It's not colon cancer.
So the frequencies that you're using for liver cancer would still be appropriate.
Yeah, breast cancer that metastasized to the adrenal gland or to the bone, it's still breast cancer cells in the bone or the adrenal gland.
It's not adrenal cancer or a bone cancer.
So you still should be running the same frequencies.
Now, if you have metastasis to bone, it might be appropriate to add some bone building frequencies.
It might be appropriate to add some other frequencies.
It might always be appropriate to be running other day programs based upon other comorbidities you might be dealing with.
There are blood building programs, for instance, for a person who has no hemoglobin.
So it may be appropriate to run those as well.
But in your case, it's not important need necessarily change your frequencies.
Are there supplements like modified citrospector or monotonicidin that can help with the testisis?
Typically, those are going to help with distant metastasis, eating through the blood stream to a distant organ.
So modified citrospector can be beneficial for that.
Really, there's no harm.
If anybody takes modified citrospector, that's the pectosol C.
Anybody can take that to help prevent metastasis.
It works as a mild key later to for other things.
So it can be beneficial for other things other than cancer.
And you know how big of a fan of artimistic and I am talk about viral infections.
Artimistic is a key component to fight viral infections as well.
And you know how big of a fan of artimistic and I am talk about viral infections as well.